se cumple una semana de la invasión rusa
a Ucrania y ya son 2000 fallecidos
[Música]
de reunión extraordinaria la votación
espera
y la agencia de Naciones Unidas para los
refugiados ya reporta
874,000 ucranianos que huyeron de la
invasión rusa la mayoría hacia la Unión
Europea el presidente de francés
Emmanuel macron anunció que acoger a los
niños huérfanos de la guerra analizamos
en esta emisión
[Música]
las noticias
según el gobierno ucraniano mientras que
Rusia reconoció 400 son 98 de su lado en
El séptimo día de combate las tropas
rusas han intensificados sus ataques a
la ciudad de ucranianas y cierran el
cerco a kiev el crimen aseguró haberse
tomado la ciudad de jerson algo que ha
desmentido el gobierno devoló y
mircelensqui argumentando que solo
controla el puerto ubicado en el
estratégico
una guerra total una guerra que afecta a
distintas partes del país en la que está
Sabiendo en Ucrania dónde se ha
estrellado un misil misil interceptado
por las fuerzas sucralianas que ha caído
sobre un gasoducto que ahora amenaza con
dejar a miles de familia sin calefacción
en pleno invierno con bajas temperaturas
esta guerra sin embargo también se está
convirtiendo en la guerra de información
según Moscú se habrán producido unas 500
bajas entre sus tropas mientras que
Ucrania habla de 5000 soldados rusos
fallecido desde el comienzo del
conflicto hace una semana lo que sí
sabemos es que 800,000 ucranianos y unos
50.000 extranjeros han abandonados o sea
el país en el intento desesperado de
huir de las autoridades que continúa
producirse en distintos puntos del país
una situación Por tanto muy complicada
en este en Ucrania en un momento en el
que continúa la negociaciones pasa una
negociaciones de paz que sin embargo
todavía no dejan prever Cuáles pueden
ser las soluciones para este conflicto
ni cuando estas soluciones se harán
públicas y llegarán a los resultados
definitivo
rusa de Ucrania y exigió el retiro de
las tropas del cremine sin embargo esta
no tiene peso jurídico la decisión se
alcanzó por amplia mayoría tras dos días
de sesión extraordinaria convocada por
el consejo de seguridad previamente
Rusia ve todo una resolución similar en
el consejo permanente Alba Santana
la asamblea general de la ONU condena la
invasión rusa a Ucrania así lo ratifica
una resolución aprobada en una sesión
extraordinaria de emergencia que deplora
la agresión Ucrania y demanda La
retirada inmediata de las tropas de
Moscú
a favor de la resolución y cada firma de
los países que votaron a favor es una
confirmación histórica de la carta de la
ONU es muy fácil señores y señores
firmar la carta en tiempos de paz es el
deber firmar
la carta en tiempos de guerra
permanente en el texto no se menciona
nada sobre el golpe ilegal a kiev en
febrero del 2014 cuando con la
convivencia de Alemania Francia Polonia
y el apoyo de Estados Unidos cerró cual
presidente legítimamente elegido del
país
a Rusia diplomáticamente ya duramente
golpeada tras las sanciones económicas
de occidente por su agresión a Ucrania
la agencia de Naciones Unidas para los
refugiados dijo que ya son
874,000 los desplazados por la guerra en
Ucrania de ellos 96,000 son ucranianos
que viajaron desde la región separatista
del Don vas hasta Rusia del lado europeo
el presidente de francés Emmanuel macron
repitió que el viejo continente se
prepara para continuar recibiendo a los
miles de qué buscan un lugar seguro y
anuncia un plan especial para [__] a
los niños huérfanos por el conflicto
obligados al exilio
y vamos al análisis con Luciana
michapolitóloga directora del centro de
estudio de política internacionales de
la Universidad de Buenos Aires y ex
coordinadora de derecho internacional
humanitario del Ministerio de defensa de
Argentina Luciana Gracias por estar con
nosotros especial las continuas
declaraciones europeas de brazos
abiertos a los refugiados está el bloque
preparado para el influjo creciente de
personas ya nos acercamos al millón
y esto parece que va a continuar dado
las cuestiones operativas
sino que van a tener que hacer un plan
integral
países europeos para poder dividirse ese
peso para poder apoyar debidamente a
todo este grupo en situación de
vulnerabilidad que más que nada son
mujeres niños y personas adultas en este
sentido mira y otro tema es la crítica a
un manejo racista de la crisis no solo
por las denuncias de mayor dificultad
para los afrodescendientes en sus
intentos de evacuación sino porque hay
puertas abiertas pero ucranianos frente
refugiados que por décadas han oído de
la violencia en países africanos esa
hora tiempo para librar también esta
discusión
Me parece que no es el momento para
liberar esta discusión en una en una
situación de conflicto armado tan
pensionado como está en este momento y
con las bombas literalmente cayendo en
varias ciudades de Ucrania el momento Es
que la principios humanitarios de no
distinción ante la violencia y la cojo a
la población civil sea total un anime y
que esto abarque como dije antes
muchísimos organizaciones que están en
este momento en el terreno y los países
que van a hacer la acogida a esposa
tanto todos los sectores están
diferentes razas como también diferentes
religiones mira y finalmente rápidamente
le pregunto qué opina usted desde el
anuncio de macron es que prevee a [__]
a niños huérfanos de la guerra es
adelantarse mucho a los acontecimientos
o llega en buen momento
me parece que es un poco adelantarse a
los momentos no creo que haya en este
momento tantos niños huérfanos hay que
esperar son 6 días nada más va a haber
obviamente huérfanos hay solo por lo que
los reportes están hablando ahí solo no
hay muchísimos son 2000 personas que han
muerto pero
se entiende que la familia ucranianas
están tratando de acoger a los huérfanos
también ellos y que no pierdan su
identidad que eso también es importante
en todo lo que tiene que ver con el
desplazamiento a través de los
diferentes conflictos armados que
lamentablemente el mundo está viviendo
en este momento más que nada el de
Ucrania que por lo que se ve en esto
Solo 6 días casi un millón de
desplazamiento forzado de población es
un número muy alto
y celebro la declaraciones de Francia y
espero también que latinoamérica esté a
la altura de las circunstancias y
podamos También nosotros prever un plan
también apoyando a los esfuerzos lo
veremos lo veremos hoy Gracias a usted
por su análisis analista desde Argentina
Mientras tanto España anunció que
enviará material bélico este viernes a
Ucrania en un cambio de postura tras
asegurar que la ayuda española Solo
sería con fondos económicos detalles con
nuestra corresponsal en Madrid Marina
Colorado
la ministra de defensa española detalló
que el país este mismo viernes enviará
material bélico a Ucrania en concreto
más de 1300 lanzagranadas 700.000
cartuchos de ametralladora y ella
metralladoras ligeras el anuncio llego
algunas horas después de que el mismo
presidente Pedro Sánchez revelara en el
congreso de los diputados y para
sorpresa de muchos Este cambio de
posición ya que El Ejecutivo había
repetido en varias ocasiones
a la entrega de material que ya va a
hacer la Unión Europea a través del
fondo europeo de apoyo a la paz el
cambio de opinión viene dado según la
ministra de defensa española por la
rápida evolución de los hechos en
ucranianos
En España se llevaba pidiendo desde que
se produjeron los primeros ataques hace
una semana sin embargo la decisión no ha
sentado muy bien a algunos de los socios
del
era que España solo enviará material
humanitario para algunos de los
integrantes de unidad podemos el envío
de más material bélico solo ayudará a
escalar el conflicto
entre tanto en Estados Unidos hay una
diáspora de cerca de un millón de
ucranianos las manifestaciones para
mostrar su apoyo a Ucrania y para
condenar la invasión del presidente ruso
Vladimir putinez sobre el territorio de
Europa del este se han extendido por
todo el país y hasta la celebridades se
han pronunciado al respecto
[Música]
a
Estados Unidos
necesitamos ayuda para seguir vivos
Estatua de la Libertad se vistió con los
colores de Ucrania mientras que una
bandera Gigante se desplegó en Times
Square Nueva York que es la ciudad de
estadounidense con mayor población
ucraniana y donde se ubica el barrio
conocido como la pequeña Ucrania aquí la
ong razón que significa juntos en
ucraniano está trabajando para reunir
suministros que ayuden a salvar vidas y
ha creado un corredor desde Estados
Unidos hasta Ucrania para entregarlos
[Música]
los sonidos de este coro tradicional
ucraniano sonaron en las alas de todo el
país el icónico programa Saturday
nightlife rindió homenaje la leyenda del
pop estadounidense Madonna se pronunció
en instagram publicando un video de uno
de sus seguidores contra la invasión de
Putin el cantante estadounidense Lenny
Kravitz de Padre ucraniano tuitió su
apoyo mientras que la pareja de
Hollywood Blake Life y Ryan Reynolds
anunciaron que recaudarán hasta 1 millón
de dólares en donaciones para ayudar a
los refugiados ucranianos por su parte
la ópera del mes de Nueva York anunció
que dejará de trabajar con artistas que
apoyen al presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
un mensaje llevado al mismo escenario
Mientras que el elenco de Don Carlos
entonaba el himno nacional ucraniano
antes de su presentación
y finalizamos con otras noticias la
asamblea de Naciones Unidas para el
medio ambiente aprobó en nairobi un
acuerdo histórico para crear el primer
tratado global contra la contaminación
de plásticos casi 200 naciones acordaron
por unanimidad en la medida su alcance
de cubre todo el ciclo de vida del
plástico y podría introducir en nuevas
reglas sobre su producción el rediseño
de productos para facilitar el reciclaje
y también la mejor eliminación de los
residuos la organización o para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico se
calcula que existen 30 millones de
toneladas de plástico en los mares y
otros 109 millones de toneladas en los
ríos
usted recuerde que la ampliación de esta
y otras noticias puede encontrarla en
nuestro sitio web Francia 24.com y
continuamos con el cubrimiento constante
de la invasión en Rusia sobre Ucrania
siga con nosotros en minutos volvemos
con más
[Música]